the legend of zelda is a franchise of
games that somehow some way can pull off
any style it wants to from forest
adventures to wild west shootouts to
operating a steam locomotive there's
nothing that these games can't do and
that's especially true when it comes to
being downright creepy the game twilight
princess is one of these wildly stylized
titles and is arguably one of the
creepiest zelda games when it wants to
be mostly for obvious reasons
it features a graphical style that leans
more on the realistic side than other
titles opening the possibility for more
dark gruesome scenery and atmosphere but
one creepy scene in particular stands
out more than the undead within the
arbiter's grounds more than the demonic
possession of snow peak ruins more than
the childish screams of a power-hungry
madman if you've played the game you
know what i'm talking about and if you
haven't consider yourself warned about
spoilers there's this one cut scene that
plays right before link and midna set
out to enter the third temple the water
temple you see in the game before the
three initial temples which each reward
lincoln midna with a piece of the
ominous fused shadow artifact there are
light spirits that must be awoken these
light spirits often give the duo advice
on their journey and are even
responsible for informing link that he
is the reincarnation of the hero
fast forward past the light spirits
faron and eldon and we come to la neru
guardian of lenairu province in which
lake hylia and by extension the water
temple itself resides after laneru is
awoken the spirit proceeds to give its
advice to link but this time it does so
by way of a vision
now this vision is what i'll be breaking
down and talking about so because i'm
going to be cutting up video quite a bit
while discussing what's happening i'm
going to play it in its entirety right
now so that you have it fresh in your
mind take a look at what the light
spirit lenairu has to say to link
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
um
[Music]
laughs
[Laughter]
[Applause]
after watching the cut scene and being
thoroughly creeped out there are a
couple things that are obvious about the
scene in the first place it's obvious
that la neru is showing length vision as
a warning the powers that midna is
asking link to uncover are the very same
powers that the light spirits themselves
sealed away because the fused shadow is
an immensely powerful relic that the
goddesses themselves came to fear
secondly it's relatively obvious that
the vision uses link and ilia as
placeholders to represent other hylians
rather than representing well link and
ilia themselves
but there are more questions raised
about the actions perceived in the
vision than there are answers why did
elia try to kill link why did link kill
ilia why does link change clothes why
does he have no eyes here and here but
he does hear why is there dark like no
why are there three dark links why does
blank eyed x dark link scream at the end
and why does ilya duplicate herself and
they all collectively jump off a high
dive in slow motion while laughing
uncontrollably
[Laughter]
let's jump right in shall we breaking it
down piece by piece first off we're
shown link flying amidst nothingness he
doesn't look like he's having a bad time
but rather just like he's curious the
text we're given is a shout out to the
creation story from ocarina of time
which is a more detailed version of the
three golden goddesses creating the
world we know in game
note the same music being used
[Music]
it is important to note that when it
mentions on screen that quote all was
chaos end quote this isn't meant to
imply any sort of negative atmosphere
this simply reflects what is around link
nothing
empty black nothingness while it is true
that the word chaos does imply an
insurmountable plethora of activity or
motion when speaking of creation and
existence and concepts of infinity the
term could be used to describe both
everything and nothing link watches the
light show as the goddesses whiz by
creating the world in front of him
granting power equally to all who dwelt
in the light in other words all men are
created equal
link is represented here simply as
himself being aware of the creation
taking place around him a key concept to
remember for this entire vision is that
link is really linked when you see blue
in his eyes
link and ilia are both shown watching
the end of creation as they look at each
other with a non-verbal remark on the
wonders they just witnessed at the hands
of the goddesses
the sacred realm is described as the
lands where the goddess has descended in
zelda lore the sacred realm is a
metaphysical plane of existence parallel
to our own we then see what appears to
be the goddesses colliding and creating
the familiar triforce if we contrast
this with the creation scene from
ocarina of time we get the additional
detail that the triforce was created at
the goddess's point of exit from our
world the next information we're given
is that the creation lived in peace
until word of the sacred realm spread
throughout hyrule this wouldn't be a
problem if the sacred realm didn't house
the triforce which has been the pivotal
relic responsible for the entire legend
of zelda series due to its promise of
granting the user's wish we're then
shown ilya holding a knife immediately
after which we see her eyes have gone
blank signifying this is no longer ilia
we're looking at this is representative
of even the most innocent of citizens in
hyrule coveting the omnipotent power of
the triforce and turning on one another
in bloodthirsty battle
the battle that the vision refers to
doesn't have a confirmed timeline
placement but we can most likely assume
that it references the infamous hyrulian
civil war which fun fact was the same
war that was responsible for sending the
hero of time's mother into the lost
woods to give her son also known as the
hero of time into the care of the great
deku tree and thus spawn the events of
ocarina of time
link or rather the individual's link
represents defeats ilya and proceeds to
run towards his goal the triforce
the cut to the next scene shows link
running but now he's clothed in his
heroic garb for some reason this may
seem like a small adjustment but it's
actually hugely impactful as it
signifies the transition from a
storytelling perspective to a very neat
half storytelling half warning section
of the vision and here's how that makes
sense
link is running towards the triforce
right
think again he's actually running
towards the fused shadow which is
actually what he's doing in game at the
time
trying to regain the pieces of the fused
shadow for midna
the fact that you can see his blue eyes
and the signature green tunic and the
fused shadow overlapping the triforce
signifies this on the other hand the
story is still being told historically
of how unwanted intruders known as the
interlopers and being played by three
dark links appeared from among those
that dwelt in the light
they wielded powerful magic and are
shown to grant themselves access to the
sacred realm the fact that they are dark
links is a powerful message in and of
itself
because dark link represents the
darkness inside link himself
dark link is a picture of the evil
potential inside every living being
which ties into the message of this
vision
it switches back to a warning message
when they're shown vaporizing link and
duplicating his exact appearance on one
of them
this is a clear message for link
directly foreshadowing what the falling
ilias tell link later on about those who
do not know or who do not fearfully
respect the power of the fused shadow
being ruled by it
the darkness inside him the dark link
becomes him but as you can see
his eyes are blank meaning this is the
dark potential inside link that has now
taken over and there is none of the hero
left inside now switching back to
storytelling mode we then see that the
fused shadow was powerful enough to
grasp the attention of the golden
goddesses themselves who ordered three
of the light spirits to intervene and
seal the fused shadow away within the
forest fire and water temples the
interlopers are caught off guard by this
as their pride blinded them to the fact
that the golden goddesses and their
creations of light were still far more
powerful than the interlopers were
the last we see of the interlopers is
the one that looks like link screaming
in horror and then just
vanishing
presumably killed by the light spirits
and nothing more said of them
this again carries a double message in
story but also warning if link does
allow the darkness inside him to take
over and be ruled by the fused shadow he
will be met with a swift and merciless
defeat by the hand of the light
after la neru reveals to link that the
power shown to corrupt man is none other
than the fused shadow we are given one
last vision
the infamous part that everybody knows
of that shows ilya a bunch of ilias
giving link a final resounding warning
then laughing while descending upside
down inexplicably
this is where the vision meets its
darkest segment the background is back
to being completely black completely
void completely nothing alike to the
beginning of the vision before creation
this means the alias we see are no
longer in creation they're outside of it
but still descending
this is representative of the afterlife
and descending into death
what we're looking at is a bunch of
ilias maniacally laughing while plunging
to their eternal slumber and it makes
link
smile he's experiencing the first
glimpse of the fused shadows power
beginning to take over he's
hallucinating about all those who would
no longer stand in his way
all those as weak as ilia he could
easily kill and rule forever
fortunately link snaps out of it before
it's too late and spoiler for the rest
of the game i suppose he doesn't get
possessed but needless to say la neru
pooled no punches when giving link this
vision of warning link could now proceed
forward knowing full well the alluring
pull of power the fused shadow commands
and that he is not immune to its evil
wiles
though it meant well in the end the
scene still lives a skin crawling memory
for those who have played through
twilight princess
and for those who have now watched this
video hey thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this creepy explanation
video please leave me a like as it'll
help get this video spread around on
youtube and subscribe if you haven't
already for much more juicy zelda
content to come comment below letting me
know what you thought of this breakdown
and if you want to see more content like
this in the future spooktober isn't over
yet folks so expect even more of the
creepy caliber in the next few weeks
as always huge thank you to all of my
patreon supporters including the new
additions sexy calzone and alex yvette
you guys are all so amazing and make my
day every day if you're interested in
getting your name on this list and other
benefits check out the link to my
patreon page in the description below
also in the description is the link to
my discord server which grows by the day
join us as we discuss all sorts of
amazing zelda topics and be in the know
for all my latest updates on mass
nintendo bandit i think that's about all
i've got for you this time so without
further ado this is mnb signing out have
a great rest of your spooky day peace
[Music]
[Music]
you